Cuckoos lay their eggs in the nests of
other birds and the movie begins with a
brief clip depicting their parasitic
life cycle and kakuchik kicks the other
Offspring out of the nest once it is
hatched and the surrogate mother looks
after it after a few months the Kaku has
grown to be a frighteningly huge bird
devouring all the surrogate mother bird
has to give there are similar parasites
in the human world too Gemma is a young
kindergarten teacher one day she comes
across one of her students under a tree
in the school garden staring at two
little dead baby birds on the ground
Gemma tries to comfort the Girl by
saying that it is the law of nature
sometimes it really do be like that
though her boyfriend Tom who is a
gardener at the same school climbs down
the tree and starts consoling her as
well he then buries the chicks in order
to make the little girl feel happy as
Gemma and Tom are in a meager's salary
they do not have much property with them
except for a car more than I have both
of them plan to prepare for their future
and agree upon buying a house for
themselves one day after work the couple
visits a real estate broker to collect
information about the houses they find
Martin an odd real estate salesperson
who informs them about a residential
build called Yonder the couple doesn't
seem interested in the property but
despite this Martin insists on taking
them to show a sample house the three
then drive out to the subdivision where
the houses are all identical residential
homes it's unusually quiet vacant and
unearthly Martin takes the couple on a
tour of home number nine which is fully
furnished the house even has food and
beverages inside the fridge however
before the couple can say anything
Martin disappears from the house
mysteriously annoyed by his lack of
professionalism and suspicious of the
Eerie Place Gemma and Tom immediately
try to leave Yonder but become lost
every route they take leads them back to
house number nine they can only see
identical homes as far as their eyes can
see after circling the same route for
numerous times the car runs out of gas
and they also lose the mo mobile signal
in their cell phones with no choices
left they reluctantly decide to spend
the night in house number nine inside
they try eating the food from the
refrigerator but find it tasteless the
very next morning the couple decides to
move out of the strange place after
finding a ladder inside the house Tom
climbs up onto the roof to see if he can
find a way out of Yonder to his horror
he notices that the identical homes are
stretched over thousands and thousands
of rows desperate to get out of the
place the couple decides to follow the
artificial looking Sun thinking that if
they remain on track it will lead them
out after walking continuously for
almost a day the couple suddenly gets
excited when they notice a house with
the lights on they immediately break in
but their excitement quickly turns into
disappointment when they find out that
they have been brought back to house
number nine to make matters more strange
they discover a delivery box outside the
house with pre-packaged food and other
Essentials required for their survival
okay this is exactly how I live Tom
angrily says fire to house number nine
in the hopes of attracting attention for
help the weary couple then falls asleep
on the road that night however the next
day when they wake up they are shocked
to find the house in perfect condition
along with a small newborn in a box with
the instructions raise the child and be
released the couple are bewildered by
the unprecedented turn of events but
have no choice but to raise the baby on
their own after 98 days the baby has
grown to the size of a seven-year-old
boy with an adult-like voice that mimics
Toms and gemma's voice in a strange
manner the boy calls the mother and
father but the couple despises him as he
lets out creepy high-pitched screams
when he is unsatisfied or unhappy when
he isn't absorbed by mysterious unusual
patterns on the television he
attentively watches and mimics the
couple gradually the couple's mental
health suffers as a result of living
with the strange child along with his
odd behavior sometimes it really do be
like that though their physical health
deteriorates as well during the their
time at home Tom constantly leaves
messages for help on the roof but to no
avail they also continue to get daily
supplies from the box that appears in
front of the house at the end of the day
the couple drops the emptied box outside
and it vanishes in an instant one day
Tom asks the boy if he has taken the box
but he remains silent [__] you Dad bored
of his life Tom does absolutely nothing
but sit in the garden every day waiting
for someone to arrive and collect or
drop the Box however no one ever comes
the boxes just appear and disappear
eerily one day after throwing a lit
cigarette on the lawn Tom notices that
yonder's soil is comprised of an
apparently man-made material so he
begins digging a hole and soon becomes
fascinated with it digging gives him a
sense of purpose as he wants to create a
tunnel and Escape through it Tom's life
has now changed every day he finishes
his meal in a hurry and starts digging
the hole in the garden until night
because of this he starts talking less
with Gemma and grows distant from her
sometimes he even falls asleep at the
bottom of the hole it's another ordinary
day an exhausted Gemma sits on the floor
of the living room watching the boy play
after a while the boy turns on the TV
which shows creepy and bizarre patterns
but he seems to be mesmerized by them
you never know what the next fat is
gonna be on YouTube after digging the
whole day Tom joins Gemma inside their
car at night he says that the car is the
only thing that he feels is real in the
whole of Yonder as the couple is
chatting Tom accidentally hits the radio
and to their surprise there is still
some power to turn it on being away from
The Real World for long the couple is
delighted to hear soulful music and
can't help but dance to it both of them
seem happy after a long time the creepy
boy also joins them and starts dancing
but suddenly an angry Tom picks him up
and slams him onto the ground Gemma
quickly goes to check on him and to her
relief the boy is fine in the next scene
Gemma is seen tucking the boy into bed
she explains why she and Tom can't be
with them all the time when she is about
to leave the boy to sleep he abruptly
calls her there however Gemma corrects
him saying that she is not his mother
this angers the freak boy and he starts
screaming at the top of his lungs like
this
Gemma tries to silence him but when he
does not oblige she simply slams the
door and goes to bed a depressed Gemma
then tries to be intimate with Tom but
he refuses and apologizes for not being
in the mood the following day the boy
walks into the door and wakes the couple
up with a loud scream all of them then
head for breakfast after eating Tom
continues digging the hole and hears a
strange sound coming from underneath
later that night he wakes up hearing the
same strange sound he then reaches the
living room only to find the sound
coming from the TV that the boy is
watching Tom turns the television off
but the boy turns it on again
immediately Gemma also tries to make him
obey but the boy refuses at last they
simply leave the room and let him be
just let it go he loves watching Andrew
Tate it's too late for him the next
morning the boy again screams to get the
breakfast served this time however Tom
loses his cool picks up the creep and
locks him inside the car he wants to
starve the boy in hopes of bringing out
the person behind the devious game Gemma
tries to intervene but Tom holds her and
drags her inside the house he says that
from now on he is not going to let her
help the boy however when Gemma hears
the boy scream and struggle inside the
car she snatches the keys from Tom and
rescues him this strains the couple's
relationship even more as the days pass
Gemma continues to take care of the boys
it is the only thing that makes her feel
better she finds that he is incapable of
imagining or picturing things Tom's
emotional remoteness with Gemma makes
her even closer to the boy she plays
games with him every day and even takes
him to picnics out on the grass one day
the boy goes missing and Gemma can't
find him anywhere at night he finally
returns with a weird textbook written in
a terrifying and unknown language I
talked to cthulu Mama Gemma asks the boy
who gave him the book but he doesn't
speak a word so she asks him to at least
mimic the person and this time the boy
obliges he then demonstrates by
expanding his neck sacks like a toad
while producing strange noises
no no Gemma starts crying in horror and
despair for she can't stand the creepy
boy any longer neck sacks are the last
straw she pleads that she wants to go
home but the boy smiles and replies that
she is home in the next scene another 98
days have passed by the creepy boy is
now matured into an adult Gemma is
scared of the freak and contemplates
with Tom that they should have killed
the boy by this time the couple
especially Tom has become much weaker
and he has bruises on his back realizing
that they don't have much time left
Gemma takes matters into her own hands
one day she follows the freak when he
gets out of the house hoping to find an
exit route however she soon loses sight
of him and gets lost meanwhile Tom
discovers a withered corpse in a body
bag while Excavating the hole scared he
immediately gets out of the hole and at
the same time hears gemma's cries for
help they shout for each other and
eventually unite but when they try to
enter the house they cannot it turns out
the freak has locked them outside Gemma
then drags an exhausted Tom inside the
car and both of them spend their night
there after days without food Tom
becomes extremely fragile and is close
to death when the freak comes out of the
house during the day Gemma pleads with
him to save Tom but he ignorantly
replies that it's time for Tom to be
released a helpless Gemma then carries
her husband in her arms and both of them
remain at the sidewalk reminiscing about
how they met after a while Tom
tragically passes away in her arms he
never even had a chance to create
Facebook or fight Superman later the
freak returns with a box which contains
a vacuum bag he Zips Tom's dead body
into it and then throws it into the same
pit that Tom had dug the next morning a
furious Gemma tries to kill the freak
with Tom's pickaxe but she only manages
to wound him slightly he makes strange
noises
and mysteriously opens the streets with
his hands before retreating into the
underground maze unwilling to give up
Gemma follows the freak inside the maze
the place is scary and looks like a
colorful haunt house Gemma is taken
aback as she sees identical homes where
other young couples are living similar
lives in the same house with the same
freak boy she realizes that everything
she sees resembles her life in Yonder
she also sees that all the couples ended
up dying in the end a depressed Gemma is
then sucked back into the same house
number nine there she realizes that they
were imprisoned in this community right
from the moment they arrived Gemma
collapses on the floor and closes her
eyes anticipating death the last thing
she remembers is the freak zipping her
inside a vacuum bag and saying that a
mother's purpose is to raise a kid and
die after Gemma passes away the freak
Chucks her into the same pit where Tom
is resting and buries the hole after
this the freak Paints the house back to
its original condition he then refuels
the car and departs the community back
to the same real estate agent where Tom
and Gemma once went the man who
recommended Tom and Gemma is still there
but is old and has reached the end of
his cycle the freak then takes the name
away from him and takes over his place
before beginning his new post the new
Martin rolls up his predecessor's body
and places it in a file cabinet the
movie ends as Martin welcomes a new
couple searching for the house of their
dreams I guess this movie was saying
something about the American dream and
Suburban living but uh the only moral I
got was sometimes a doobie like that
though subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching